Sự tế thành phố Chí Minh cho biết tảm mê ba phần chăm mẫu mệ phẩm COVID-19 được sải trình từ dễn tại thành phố mang đến Trung Lợ B,
chấm một chấm tảm chấm một biến tế phụ của ZOM XD về chấm một, khiến thành từ sự tải tổ học giữa gì nở chấm một và XD.
Bến Trung này có tốt lộ lời là nhanh đã xuất hiện tại 2.2 cức ra.
Tư tình mùi sau đến tình 2 mươi, số ca mắc COVID-19 tại thành phố Tăng Sóa Zet, Trung mình mùi mô ca một tình,
nhưng tần 2 mươi giận 2 mươi sau cả.
Du trước có ca bệnh nặng ngàn I. Tiến phẩm của phuyên cáo không trục quan.
Bến Trung được bây lướng chấm một chấm tảm chấm một có cất đột biến tai phụng giữa bây đế phó lụ thể indài
Tế bón bệ tảm I, A, bón B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, Đam Hát, lâm tăng hản răng bán vào tế bọng hồi người là nhệng.
Chở chấm thứ nhện như bất học, Đau học, mệt mồi, nhìn có thể kéo dài giễn môi cạk ướn.
Bộ ít tế yêu cầu các địa phương giả sốt kế vải thu dung, điều chỉ bảo đam cứ sử vật chất, vật tư, như lực ít tế.
Nhóm nghĩ cơ cao như người cao tuổi, bệnh nền phụ nữ mặt thay cần được thật giỏi sát và yêu tiền tiêm nhất lại vật sinh.
Người dân được huyên cao thứ tục đào khẩu trang, dựa tay sát quần, hạn chỉ tụ tập và chủ động đi khám khi có chữ chữ.